[Musica]
guido speranze è stato il mio paziente è
vero perché è stato lui per la prima
volta a mostrarmi la
possibilità di passare da un prima e un
dopo da un'idea che le persone hanno di
loro e la possibilità di cambiarla
l'ho conosciuto perché lo inviarono i
medici aveva avuto una diagnosi di
malattia e ricordo perfettamente la
prima frase che mi disse sono qua perché
loro i medici gli hanno inviato io non
ne sentivo la necessità
ho sempre pensato
di fare bene alla mia vita perché poi
dottoressa sono sempre stato
fortunato la fortuna per guido speranze
era una parte importantissima della sua
vita
ma quand'è che aveva cominciato a
pensarlo
quand'è che un'idea entra nelle vostre
teste
e vi accompagna per tutta la vita magari
e vi potrebbe condizionare senza che voi
ve le passate accordo
allora chiesi a guido speranza
quand'è che per la prima volta penso di
essere fortunato
perché a tutti capita prima o poi di
sentirsi dire sono che sei fortunato
pensare di essere fortunato allora lui
cercò nella sua memoria
e mi raccontò di quella volta in prima
liceo che torno a casa felice e contento
aveva preso un bellissimo voto in
matematica l'odissea sua madre sua madre
si era la sera
lo racconto a cena
e venne interrotta dalla fase del
fratello di guido che disse o guido
rossi stato fortunato
ma poi uno studente andare bene a scuola
perché fortunato
lasciamo da parte tutti quelli che cocco
che per caso uno studente possa andare
bene a scuola e chi studia
ammettiamo anche che uno abbia studiato
poco un po meno
dell'esagerato
ma fa una bellissima programmazione il
professore lo premia
e fortuna o è la capacità di quella
persona di avere colto i concetti chiave
di averli tradotti nella sua bellissima
interrogazione
ma mettiamo anche che un ape proprio
studiato poco poco poco
pero riesca a portare a casa un bel 6
quando pensava di portare a casa un 4
e fortuna capacità
e la capacità di quella persona di aver
creato una buona relazione con
l'insegnante di avere
preso dalle sue memorie quella parte che
gli ha permesso di portare a casa il
cell
cosa accadrebbe se noi
iniziassimo a cambiare l'idea della
fortuna
chiesi a guido speranza durante i nostri
colloqui di non usare più la parola
fortuna di fare un esercizio
un esercizio che vi se vi piaceva lo
potrete fare anche voi tornando a caso
nei prossimi giorni ripensando a questa
giornata
che vi
di togliere
dalle nostre conversazioni dei nostri
colloqui e la parola fortune di
sostituirla con sono stato capace sono
capace
per poterlo fare però
perché è difficile come esercizio e se
voi ci ripensa a te se voi ci state
pensando in questo momento vi
accorgerete che tantissime volte voglio
dita di voi stessi e degli altri
molte volte più degli altri quando dice
dite siete stati capaci siete stati
fortunati a portare a casa quel
risultato
e allora
chiesi a guido speranza di iniziare a
parlare di capacità e per poterlo fare
presi in presto un termine
dal dal campo della sicurezza sul lavoro
né armi né armis sono gli eventi che
potevano andare
gravi che potevano essere mortali gli
infortuni che non sono accaduti
nella sicurezza sul lavoro si studiano
questi eventi che potevano essere
drammatici ma che poi non si sono
verificati per una serie di coincidenze
per poter fare prevenzione
faccio un esempio
sull'impalcatura c'è un operaio
accidentalmente dimentica il martello
passa di lì un altro operaio
e
accidentalmente di nuovo urta il
martello quello cade precipita ma non
colpisce all'operaio di sotto
questo normalmente viene chiamato colpo
di fortuna
la sicurezza sul lavoro va analizzare
questo evento e cerca di capire che cosa
è accaduto
quale comportamento poteva essere
introdotto per evitare un possibile
incidente o quale comportamento
accertato che ha evitato il posto
dell'incidente
e allora chiesi a guido di ripensare un
evento della sua vita un evento
rischioso dove lui aveva pensato di
essere stato fortunato
ci pensa
e si ricordò di una volta da bambino
aveva sei anni era andato con il bob in
un bellissimo campo pieno di neve
insieme ai suoi fratelli e agli amici
quando fu il suo turno lo salì sul bot
con la sorella e poi si buttarono giù
lungo questo campo
ma invece di andare verso l'uscita del
campo
presero la direzione sbagliata e
andarono verso il filo spinato
ma dottoressa per un colpo di fortuna
ci sdraiamo sul bob e passammo sotto il
filo spinato ci ricorda ancora la paura
di quel giorno è il film che mi passava
sopra poco poco distante dal volto
bene
guido realizziamo la stessa storia ma
guardiamola in modo diverso
perché salì sul blog con sua sorella a
lei disse vieni con me e io avrei scelto
lei tra mille perché lei mi ha sempre
dato sicurezza
ma poi quando siete scesi da questo
campo cosa è accaduto perché voi vi
sdraiate vi appoggiate la portata e la
schiena sul botta e
dottoressa c'è stato un balzo guido e
dottoressa aspetti dalla dottoressa mia
sorella mi approccio mi prese e io mi
lasciai andare a lei
insieme
passammo sotto
ma dopo guido siete tornati sul campo no
proprio pericoloso quel gioco
allora guido mi faccia capire
ha scelto sua sorella
sua sorella ha avuti riflessi pronti e
lei si è fidato di sua sorella
e alla fine avete anche scelto di non
fare quel gioco pericoloso
allora guido voi siete stati capaci
certo è ovvio era molto meglio che guidò
non corresse quel rischio quel giorno
però quante volte a voi è capitato nella
vita di correre dei rischi
avete anche rischiato magari di morire o
di farvi molto male ma non è accaduto
e voi avete detto per fortuna e invece
no perché eravate sobri avevate scelto
la persona giusta
è arrivati i riflessi pronti
e siete magari stati attenti ma cosa
accadrebbe se da qui uscendo da oggi in
poi non sorte più la parola fortuna è
iniziata dire che siete capaci
forse non succederebbe nulla o forse
tutto cambierebbe
ma cosa accadrebbe se un genitore un
insegnante un medico una persona che si
relazione col prossimo chiunque un amico
dicesse agli altri sei stato capace
siete voi che conoscete le vostre storie
voi potete andare a rileggere tutte e
solo voi lo potete fare andare a
rileggere quelle storie belle o meno
belle che avete svalorizzato con un
semplice colpo di fortuna
vedete
guido speranza è stato capace
limitare a parlare di se stesso e degli
altri con molto rispetto
pensando di essere parte di un processo
decisionale
noi gli diamo una vita pensando di poter
controllare tutto ma molte cose sono
fuori controllo e molte volte le persone
hanno paura del fuori controllo ma non
pensano che molte volte quel fuori
controllo può essere
governato dalle proprie capacità dalle
proprie possibilità di vedere quello che
riescono a fare
io vado concludere ma ho una sorpresa
per voi
guido speranza equa e io ve lo voglio
presentare io spero che siate felici di
conoscerlo perché giunta l'ora che anche
voi lo conosciate lo volete conoscere
più convinti
giratevi sulla vostra destra
lo vedete è la parte migliore di chi vi
sta accanto
è la parte migliore di voi
in ognuno di voi c'è un grido speranza
tu sei il tuo paziente zero tusa il tuo
paziente vero tu sei il tuo paziente
zero
perché sarà la capacità
di permettervi di capire che potete
partire da un prima che è il vostro
pensiero per arrivare a un dopo che è il
futuro che vorrete futuro io
[Applauso]
[Musica]